brian is with us in Biloxi Mississippi
hi Brian how are you good Dave how you
doing better than on dessert what's up
hey just just got our thousand dollars
emergency fund in the bank ready to
start start the debt snowball my wife
and I have sat down and gone through all
the forms and everything and and I've
been an agreement on most things and we
kind of see a little differently here on
the damage done to your house 132 K on
what ah let's see it was that carpet
rings credit cards swimming pool both
cars
hmm you guys been buying crap like
you're in Congress hadn't you uh yeah
pretty much okay and how much your
household income we bring home ninety
two hundred a month hmm so you make good
money at least you'll be able to clean
this up probably need to sell a bunch of
that crap too don't you uh well I
emailed her today and said I'm selling
the boat and she said no that's our only
source of entertainment mm-hmm and
vacation how old are you two I am 39
she's 37 all right well I mean you guys
just got to decide what your life goals
are what we what we do run is we help
people who want to win with money and
have dignity with money if you want to
stay deeply in debt we're going to
follow your wife's advice if you want to
get out of that so that you get your
life back because you make 120 thousand
dollars a year you sit freaking broke if
you want to fix that you're going to
have to sacrifice some things because
you guys have been doing stupid with
steroids around that place by the way I
know what that looks like because I've
done stupid with steroids I've done
Dumber things and you and your wife put
together so I know what stupid looks
like so I'm not picking on you now I
guess I'm just picking on the decisions
you made up to this point and if you
keep making decisions like you've been
making you're going to keep getting what
you've been getting gotcha so my
understanding with this debt snowball
Dave is that we allocate our money the
necessities listen we put our thousand
dollars in saving just every extra penny
goes to pay off the debt the smallest
debt yes most at first then we move
forward so we're not we're not putting
extra into the save
account we're just the thousand no no
savings at all no investing and I'll
stop 401ks temporarily now how much do
you owe on your cars
mine is twenty seven thirty four and the
boats worth what I'm thirty okay and you
guys just started this process right uh
yes sir how long ago did you first
introduce to this whole idea uh
Financial Peace University yes sir oh
well we bought the package three years
ago we just dusted it off last month
alright and so you haven't gone through
the class no just doing all about at
home stuff on the DVD that's your
mistake you need to go to a class and
the two of you need to have go through
the experience of this before you start
trying to talk her into selling the boat
because here's the problem you're
running into with her she still her mind
is still over there with the other stuff
the other way of doing things the way
y'all used to do things and your mind
has moved past that and you now are
concerned that this is not working
she's not as concerned as you and until
she catches up with you you're going to
run into tremendous resistance okay and
say you guys have to sit down and dream
again about what it would be like to
make a hundred and twenty hundred thirty
thousand dollars a year and have no
payments and you're not doing that right
now and so she's just holding on to
things like a four-year-old the serial
out and it's not it's not because she's
a bad person she just you're just about
two steps further down this brand-new
journey than she is and you're starting
to see that this could work and so
you're saying hey it's worth giving up
some things now so that later we can
have a life we'll live like no one else
so later we can live like no one else
right but if I could get both of you
excited about how wealthy you could
become and how much you could give and
how you could enjoy good vacations and
cars and boats for the rest of your life
by sacrificing now the more excited I
could get you after having done this for
twenty years I can see your numbers real
quickly and clearly once I got both of
you that excited I would sell everything
you freakin own neither one of you have
a car you both be in thousand-dollar
cars on sale your boat - it's absolutely
freakin insane all right you guys have
you guys had thousands of dollars on a
payments on those
almost three things right I mean y'all
literally it's just nuts but you're not
there yet that's just me observing and
I'm 20 years further along this journey
than you guys are so I'm not mad at you
I want you to win and that's how I would
look at it so if I were you I would look
for a Financial Peace University class
in your area by buying the home study
course you have a free access to that go
to the class and the two of you just sit
there don't talk her into anything just
say honey I want to go this class I want
to change our life I want to be able to
win and quit talking to her about
selling the car until you talk to other
boat till you talk about why we're
selling the boat this is the Dave Ramsey
ship
you